One thing I'd like to expose you really quickly is
RSS, you've probably heard of RSS before. It's how you
read a website that has, you know, daily content, you
know, like a blog or a news site and you may
have a reader that is specialized for just reading the content. RSS stands for
RDF Site Summary, and, RDF stands for Resource Description Framework. Now
I'm not going to quiz you on this, RDF is, is an XML format for describing just
about anything. For basically representing knowledge in XML actually
in my first job I dealt with a lot of
RDF so, I don't want to spend any more
time on it. More commonly, RSS actually refers to Really
Simple Syndication and that's kind of more of more
of the context of how we're going to be dealing with
it. You know, RDF was kind of conceived to solve
this grand data, you know, organize the world's information problems.
And RSS was, you know, it uses RDF but really, its
just a list of, a list of content in XML. So
let me show you some more example of this in the
wild. I'm at the New York Times home page right now,
and if we go down to the bottom of this page,
we'll see a link for RSS, so I'll click that link,
and I'll choose the New York Times global home page. Now,
you can see in our URL, we have GlobalHome.xml. And so
we've received an XML document. And most browsers will
actually display XML in a nice way. So, this
is an XML document. It's actually an RSS. And
so, what this basically means is there's a, a particular
namespace, kind of a tag space if you will,
for the items in this list. You know, just
like HTML has, you know, opens with an HTML
and has a body and, you know, very specific tags.
An RSS document will also, has specific tags. And
in XML, you can use as header area, to describe
what name spacing's used. So were using the atom
name space, and the RSS 2.0 name space. And that's
basically what this is telling our parser, is you
can download a kind of descriptions of these tags from
these URLs. And then we know what tags to expect.
We're not going to, I'm not going to quiz you on what
RSS actually is, so if you take a, a little peak at this
document, you can see it starts out with some header stuff kind of in
this channel section and then when we get down to this list of items.
And so I'm going to collapse these first few and we can see we've got
an item and this is basically just a list of stories that are
in the New York times. So I can collapse and item and we can
see if there is another item. There's actually a whole bunch of items. And
each item has, you know, a title, and a link, and sorts of things
that you know, would power an RSS reader. You know, a little description.
You know, this is, this is neat. This is for an RSS reader,
or a program to download the contents of the New York Times without
having to parse all the HTML. Which brings us to our next quiz.